hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll back when i started blogging so
like 2004 2005 the hot topic in the
science blogosphere believe it or not
was creationism and intelligent design
and the battle with natural selection
and darwinian evolution it was a big
story it was not just on blogs even the
new york times was writing about this i
don't hear about this that much anymore
i mean i'm sure it's still happening i'm
sure that there are still people trying
to get intelligent design in high
schools or whatever but you don't hear
about it that much it makes me wonder
what the connection is between what
happens in the world and what you hear
about right what the hot topics are what
people are actually talking about it's
probably a pretty flimsy connection in
some sense but anyway that is not the
point of this podcast the point is that
i thought about it because one of the
issues that is always brought up by
people who are in favor of creationism
or intelligent design
is that there are capacities that living
creatures have that don't seem naively
evolvable by a series of small
incremental steps they even tried to
quantify this idea in the notion of
irreducible complexity something that
was very complex and functional but if
you removed any piece of the operation
it would be completely useless and the
idea was that things like the eye would
be hard to imagine growing gradually
in fact that's completely nonsense eyes
are one of the easiest things to grow
gradually even in a more simplified
context one of the examples was a mouse
trap you know if you remove any piece
from a mouse trap it doesn't do anything
of course someone instantly invented a
reducible mousetrap that you could build
up piece by piece i even wrote about it
in the big picture so the lesson was
that things that you are skeptical can
be built up piece by piece are actually
very buildable so you have some good
science came out of that understanding
uh how that works one such example is
flight right either you fly or you don't
in some very naive sense but even
thinking about it a little bit you know
that's not true there's floating there's
gliding there's jumping there are all
sorts of halfway houses to flying
nevertheless the question of how flight
actually arose through biological
evolution is fascinating so today we
have on the podcast richard dawkins
presumably needs no introduction and he
has a new book out called flights of
fancy defying gravity by design and
evolution
and it's a pretty broad overview of how
flight works in general not just in
biology so he includes airplanes and
spaceships and so forth and then he
compares them and he's talking about
like why does evolution in biology use
certain kinds of flight but not other
kinds of flight which is a fascinating
question to contemplate and i'll confess
we use the podcast i use the podcast to
go beyond the topic of the book talk
about biology and evolution more
generally questions of adaptation versus
randomness if you played the tape of
life once again would you get to the
same kind of ecology etc uh the
relationship between genes and
organisms and species etc because you
know look when you have richard dawkins
on the podcast you're going to want to
ask about evolution very very broadly so
we have a wide-ranging conversation
about all of those things uh and even at
the end we do a little tiny bit about
philosophy and science so i'm sure
you'll want to tune in for that so with
that let's go
[Music]
richard dawkins welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you very much
i love the idea that you've written a
book about the evolution of flying
because of course this is one of the
classic
puzzles for those of us who like to
believe in evolution you know evolution
works incrementally and flying is either
yes or no i guess in our naive
conception of it i mean why did you pick
flying as something to write about for
this book well there are things which
are yes or no but flying actually is is
not one of them because
flying you got every everywhere between
flying and gliding
just sort of soaring with with not
proper wings but just a bit of a bit of
a membrane sure um if you think about a
a leaping animal like a squirrel
which is up in the treetops and it's
leaping from branch to branch
and uh however far it can leap
without any
additional flight surface surfaces
there's just a little bit further it
could leap with a flight surface so
somewhere up there there's going to be
a
a branch distance which it could just it
could just reach
without um
a
an extra flight surface and now it can
because it's got it's got the extra
flight surface so any little membrane a
little extra flap of skin
extra fluff on the tail
anything to increase the
uh flight surface the surface area
of the of the animal will get it just an
inch further or two inches further or
three inches further
and then once it's got that much further
then there'll be another pair of
branches which are just
just within reach if it's got a slightly
larger
membrane and we see that in
the uh forests of southeast asia there
are
um a whole range of
uh and australia and africa but
especially southeast asia a whole range
of
animals which glide from tree to tree
and they have
various kinds of membrane there are
flying squirrels that have a membrane
stretching from
their front legs to their hind legs
there are flying lizards
which
stick their ribs out
and they have skin stretching between
the ribs there are flying frogs which
have large fingers long fingers and they
have extra membrane between their
fingers
um
there are marsupial gliders there are
gliders that more than one family of
rodents has developed this gliding trick
well
it's not a big step to go from there to
actual
controlled flight like a parachutist
altering the the shape of the parachute
and they do that you could watch them
they adjust their
they can steer like a parachutist can
it's not that far to go from that to
flapping
and so it's you could go to
maybe the evolution of bat flight could
come by going from having a gliding
membrane to a flapping membrane and
there's a lot of uh
benefits to this clearly but you already
brought up something i was saving for
later but let's get right into it which
is the idea that
climbing into trees presumably plays a
large role in why flights developed in
the first place right like once you're
up there in the tree then there's an
evolutionary pressure to get better at
gliding and jumping in a way that it's
even more than if you're just sitting on
the ground to start yes then so many
animals do do climb trees it's i mean
there's squirrels there are primates
there there's no primates that's
developed that that gliding trick there
there are gibbons that leave phenomenal
distances and swing themselves from
their arms which is almost like like
flying but they haven't developed the
extra membrane
um
oddly enough there are quite a lot of
people who believe that flight in birds
at least did not come from
being up trees
they think it came from dinosaurs birds
across our dinosaurs as you know um
leaping into the air
maybe trying to catch an insect or
trying to catch trying to pounce on a
prey
and then pouncing just that little bit
further because you have a little bit of
membrane to to increase your
surface area to catch the air
actually this is uh
pointing to something that is an
embarrassing gap in my knowledge uh i do
know that birds are
descended from dinosaurs but are they
descended from flying dinosaurs or did
flying get lost and then come back no no
um
flying there there are there are
pterodactyls which actually technically
aren't dinosaurs either but um they are
related to dinosaurs and they
independently evolved true flight
i mean true true flapping flight um
birds are descended from feathered
dinosaurs lots of dinosaurs we now know
had feathers
probably for thermoregulation purposes
originally
and birds then uh
well they are dinosaurs um they're
they're
in in the sense that they come from
within the dinosaurs and there are
dinosaurs which are more closely related
to birds than they are to other
dinosaurs so that means that birds are
really
slap bang within the middle of the
dinosaurs
um so they develop feathers for
thermoregulation purposes
and then the feathers proved useful for
a flight surface after that a very
typical evolutionary trick to repurpose
something that was developed for
something else exactly but you're
mentioning the primates is interesting
because i hadn't thought about that no
no flying primates as far as we know uh
if we don't believe in angels i suppose
um
but
is that partly because of the size
constraints i mean one of the big things
you mentioned right from the start in
the book are the physics constraints
right it's easier to fly when you are
tiny and primates tend to be big yes
that that's right um i mean there are
so-called flying lemurs
which the name suggests that they're
primates that's actually unfortunately
they're not primates i mean they're but
they are related to primates so flying
lemurs collagos
um they carry the parachute trick to its
extreme
they're they look like flying squirrels
except that the membrane goes to the tip
of the tail as well as the arms and legs
so they they're really just one big
parachute
um
if they were really lemurs then that
would be an example of a of a flying
primate but then strictly speaking
they're not primates although they're
called flying lemurs i'm going to put
you on the spot here a little bit and
ask you to talk about the physics of
size i know that i'm supposed to be the
physicist here but uh there are you know
laws relating weight versus surface area
and things like that tell us how those
go into
enabling and some animals to fly more
easily than others well i'm embarrassed
talking to a physicist about this but
for the benefit of the audience um
the uh
as you increase the the linear dimension
the size of anything it doesn't matter
whether it's an animal or a block of
wood
if you um the
the weight of the volume and therefore
weight goes up as the cube of the linear
dimension the surface area goes up as
the square of the linear dimension so
that means that the smaller you are
the relatively larger is your surface
area compared to your weight
and so um something like a dandelion
seed with a little puff little
bit of bit of fluff on it or a nat or a
mosquito
um
it's so small
that its surface area is large compared
to its weight
and so it hardly need bother to fly it
just kind of floats around in the air
um there's a tiny little insect in in
the book called tinkerbella which is
named after the fairy in peter pan
um and that's
so small we got a picture in the book of
it of it flying through the either
needle
um and so that its wings just look like
one big feather one one it's like it
just uses its wings to kind of row
through the air rather than
actually um fly in the in the ordinary
sense
so the smaller you are the easier it is
to fly if you're the size of a horse
say then flying becomes essentially
impossible that there are
there's one pterosaur yeah
quetzalcoatlus which is
maybe as heavy as a horse um and that
managed to presumably glide from from
from from high places i i think i'm
going to let you tell us a little bit
more about quetzalcoatlus because it was
it's a pretty remarkable
beast the size of a giraffe uh and you
know it seems like a little bit of an
outlier in terms of flying yeah yes
it certainly is um
i mean i think nobody knows exactly how
it flew it it must have flown it's got
it's got wings uh it probably is maybe
jumped off cliffs
who knows what it is what once up there
then and it could probably stay up there
because um you can glide um
it's about the size of a
of us a light aircraft um
about the size of a cessna uh
or piper
uh light aircraft um that's the largest
creature that ever flew as far as we
know there are some pretty big birds as
well
um there's a relative of the condor
uh which is um
uh
well considerably larger than a condo
this
thing that looked a bit like an
albatross again much much larger than an
albatross and they probably also glided
i mean it's a good example of the
constraints right not the constraints
but the uh competing interests in
evolution right i mean flying seems
like a good
ability to have all else being equal but
maybe being large is also a good ability
to have and there's a trade-off exactly
yes it's a trade-off and much of the
book actually keep coming back to this
theme of
economic trade-offs
and yes there will be a trade-off
between the advantages of being large
and the
advantage of flying but actually
flying's not
an unmitigated benefit we know that
because quite a lot of animals have
actually lost the power of flight
and there's a chapter on that yeah
something i think we call it if if
flying's so great why so many animals
lost it um the most dramatic example of
that is queen ants and queen termites
which
fly for one purpose only which is to
mate
and they take off
on on a mating flight and an ant queen
mates once in her life
only once during this mating flight and
then she settles down
and digs a hole in the ground and builds
a nest start and founds a nest before
doing so having landed on the ground she
bites off her wings
or tears off her wings in different
species so that's a very dramatic
demonstration that flying is not always
a good thing um they actually take go to
the lengths of biting off their wings in
order to
um presumably function better
underground and of course worker ants
don't have
wings
even though both their parents had wings
then there are lots of birds which when
they get to islands
lose their ability to flight to fly i
mean things like dodas right which um
must have used their wings and a dodo is
a kind of overgrown pigeon
and it must have used its wings to get
to mauritius in the first place but once
it arrived on mauritius
and there was
there was no predators worth worrying
about
and so it lost its ability to fly
and the wings shrank
and it could only then waddle around
and then became a victim of of sailors
clubbing them to death because he
couldn't escape
presumably penguins are a similar story
right well penguins
yes that's not quite the same story
because in in their case they
took up swimming instead
so they they fly underwater if you watch
how penguin actually swims it swims
using its wings
so it's its wings are optimized for
underwater flying
which means they're very small
um and um
so it as it were put all its eggs in
this one basket of swimming
whereas something like a puffin
which also flies under water but but
flies are in air as well so it has to
compromise it's an uneasy compromise
between the the best shape and size for
a wing to be under water which would be
penguin sized
and the best
um
shape and size to be in air which would
be say gull sized right and puffing is
sort of halfway between
um so it's not a very good flyer it's
not a very good swimmer but it it does
adequately well at both
i guess it's a really
good example of the way that evolution
works because what i said what i blurted
out was you know flying is clearly
advantageous and as you said not always
uh i guess what's really true is that
flying is fun right like we all want to
do it it seems like an ability we would
want to keep but evolution doesn't care
about that right evolution just says is
this good to reproductive success it
doesn't um
and uh
i i bet it is fun i think if you if you
watch gulls playing in the in the in in
the wind
it's very tempting to think it's fun um
and then you can as it were justify that
by saying well let's not call it fun
let's say they're practicing
um
that that's fair enough actually um
uh it it probably is a skill that
benefits from practice and so if you
do a bit of aerobatics in in gusts of
wind
when you're not trying to to um say
escape from predators then it might
serve you in good stead when you are
well fair enough but this does get us
right into um some deeper questions
about evolution you know when we see the
the birds uh flying around in ways that
seem like fun
to what extent can we say that's an
adaptive behavior that is training them
to be better flyers and to what extent
can we say they're just having fun and
it's not necessarily
improving their reproductive fitness in
any way
i suppose as an orthodox darwinian i
would have to say something like this
that if it were only fun
and they were actually wasting time and
wasting energy
then a rival bird
that conserved its energy and conserved
its time
would out reproduce it and so i think
there's got to be some kind of
as a loyal darwinian i'd have to say
there's got to be some kind of added
benefit
um to it to
the funds such as practice and i think
practice is a perfectly respectable
function
i think if you watch a young bird
learning to fly they clearly are
learning to fly there's no doubt about
it i mean a bird
a young
eagle
on the nest say
it sort of hops pops up and down and
flaps its wings and kind of hopping
and doesn't actually take off from the
nest but it's it's exercising its wings
and also probably
uh
maturing its flying skills as it does so
well i mean this good this is going to
get us into again the yeah the deep
issues here because
uh
it doesn't necessarily and i'm not an
expert here it doesn't necessarily seem
to me to be the case that every
activity that an animal does needs to
have some reproductive success right i
mean after all as someone once taught us
it's the genes that are selected for
and the genes could have uh various
effects some of which
are
uh advantageous traits and some of which
are just spin-offs yeah
yes that's true
um but uh
if you you in a way you've sold the past
by by using a word like fun um
and
you've almost said well because i'm
daring to use the word fun i'm
kind of conceding that it's not having
that additional
spin-off effect if it is that that's
fine of course i mean if say
um the genes are having an uh what they
call a pliotropic effect a planetropic
effect means the gene has more than one
effect perhaps in different parts of the
body
um
it could be like that but in a way that
sort of um
not addressing the issue that we're
trying to talk about we're trying to
actually have an argument about whether
and it's an interesting argument i mean
i don't see why one shouldn't argue
about whether animals are motivated by
the sheer joy of flying
and the way i was trying to
give it my best shot by suggesting that
the sheer joy of flying
uh could be useful because of practicing
for when it's really needed in earnest
so in a way to use the plyotropy
it's a bit of a cop-out you're kind of
saying well yeah maybe it's useful for
something else which is true
it could be but it's not really getting
to the heart of the
interesting discussion we were trying to
have well i mean let's ask the
philosophy of science question then um
how
so let's say that we have some purported
explanation for why this behavior is
adaptive and helps with selection
how do we know you know how do we test
that idea um whether it's just a from
plyo trophy or whether or not there's a
specific advent advantage to this
specific behavior well that's an
excellent question i don't i don't think
that's an easy one to answer as in terms
of actual evidence i think what we could
say is something like this
we have so much confidence in darwinian
theory
that it would be
uh
we would have to be throwing a lot of
useful stuff out if we were to accept
um that it was purely fun let me give
another example which is not to do with
flying but which is interesting
um
bird song
has
great aesthetic appeal or some bird
songs have great aesthetic appeal for
humans
um
as keats said of the nightingale my
heart aches and a drowsy numbness pains
my senses though of hemlock i had drunk
the the nightingale song had a drugging
effect on keats's
nervous system
and uh he would record his anesthetic
effect
but he also likened it to taking a
taking a drug
well
keith's nervous system was a vertebrate
nervous system and so is a female birds
female nightingale
so
if
the
nightingale song could have that effect
on the poet keats
why wouldn't it have a similar effect on
a female nightingale
and um
i i like this idea because
um we know that
birdsong
actually does have a measurable phil
physically logical effect on the female
bird's hormones this has been shown in
doves and in
canaries
uh it actually male song in canaries
actually causes the ovaries of a female
to grow
so it's as though the male is having a
direct hormonal effect physiological
effect on the female
um
a human physiologist
could cause a female's ovaries to grow
by injecting hormones or perhaps he
could influence her behavior by sticking
electrodes in her brain
well the male the male bird can't do
that
but he can do something equivalent which
is to sing
so
um
there was a man called hearts horn who
actually tried to make the case that
birdsong was an aesthetic that buzz had
an aesthetic it's appreciation of song
that actually enjoyed song
in the same ways we enjoy
music
and he was rather ridiculed for that
but it's not too far distant what i'm
now saying
which is that
um the manipulative effect of a male
bird song on the female physiology
um
is
kind of like an aesthetic experience now
if we go now to the question of how the
male bird learns to sing
it's been shown in a number of species
that
birds when they're when they're
developing young birds when they're
developing their song
are
teaching themselves to sing by trial and
error
so what they're doing is this has been
shown by experiments
what they're doing is
kind of bubbling around it at random and
every time they hear a phrase that they
like i use that phrase
advisedly they repeat it they so they're
they're learning they're teaching
themselves to sing
um by
repeating those phrases of burbling of
wobbling which appeal to them
turn them on
now a male nightingale or a male canary
is the same species as a female he he
has a similar brain
so whatever turns him on
might turn the female on
well that's getting perilously close to
talking about as an aesthetic experience
isn't it it's saying
um the the male teaches himself to sing
by
singing phrases at random and the ones
that he likes the ones that
turn him on
aesthetically
are likely to be the same as the one
that would turn a female on
aesthetically and sexually
so
um we can
kind of make a darwinian justification
for using the language of aesthetics
and in a similar kind of way we might do
the same thing for
uh the aesthetics of uh of a flight of
enjoying it of having fun flying and
having the
having a
fun experience of flying i mean
presumably as physicalists about the
fundamental nature of reality we don't
believe that there is something
purely human in the idea of aesthetic
enjoyment right it has to
come up there along the evolutionary
ladder so
in some sense there's there has to be
some related thing in in birds or bees
right
well maybe not actually has to be but
it's quite plausible that it this wood
that it would yes
did you see uh this is gonna sound out
of left field but did you see the um
documentary on the beatles get back that
came out recently
no the beatles the musical group not the
species of insect but uh there's a
famous clip from it in which paul
mccartney is just sitting strumming on
his bass guitar and conjuring out of the
ether uh the song get back
and he's doing exactly what you just
talked about with the writing gales he's
sort of randomly playing a couple
different things finding the ones he
likes and building upon those i believe
there are some notebooks of beethoven
which show which show
uh
development when beethoven jotted down
phrases um when he used to go out for
long walks and he had a notebook and and
he would jot down phrases and you can
see
some of the
melodies of beethoven which we now
know and love
in their embryonic form
developing through the notebook i'm not
i'm not actually seeing the notebook
itself but i believe that's the case
okay very good uh to get it back to
jeans a a little bit you know i've
wondered
for a long time and now that i have you
here there's a perfect time to ask these
questions about
the
just numerical relationships between the
number of different genes we could have
and the number of different traits we
could have so if if it would be
evolutionarily advantageous to fly or to
sing or whatever
you know how
how obvious is it that
that pressure on our abilities can
correctly shape our genes to enable that
kind of thing i don't know if this is
too vague a question but you know it's
very very interesting um is there we
have room in there i heard it put that
way quite like that before um first as
you know it's it's a fallacy to think
about um
traits as being sort of unitary
like um a butcher's diagram exactly
right
it's not like that
it's rather that what what genes are
doing is influencing
embryonic processes
so it's we think of it as a
a cooking recipe where
um
you you have a recipe which uh it
consists of a lot of words and there's
no one-to-one mapping between
words of the of the recipe and bits of
the dish that but it's a cake or
whatever it is it's rather that the
whole recipe maps onto the whole
cake right um
and a little bit of heat here a little
bit of
added milk there whatever it might be
has an effect on the embryology of the
cake
and so but that's okay that doesn't um
take away from the question you're
asking which is more
is there a gene is there a limit to the
to the detail that
uh genes are capable of
specifying yeah
um
so
something like
um birdsong
we've already talked about that and i
said that birds teach themselves to sing
by
randomly
burbling and and you could you could say
well that's because
the genes don't have the um
informational capacity to specify
something as complicated as a song it
has to be done
more indirectly than that
on the other hand uh
well
the shape of a spider website
um
it's not that the genes contain a kind
of map of what a spider web should look
like it's it's more that the
the g the genes that could specify a set
of rules
which the spider obeys and uh
the shape of the web is an emergent
property from the
uh from the rules being obeyed um
a termite mound
is a complicated
structure built by
the thousands of termites
and no termite has anywhere either in
its brain or in its genes a picture of
an of a termite mound
it's rather that each little termite is
following little local rules
um which
um when they all obey these little local
rules
what happens is that a termite mount
emerges
uh if you've ever seen
films of starlings
so-called starling murmurations sure
where these starlings flying these
gigantic flocks
thousands tens of thousands of birds
wheeling and dancing in the air in the
most spectacular
rhythm
um
uh they the whole flock looks like a
great big amoeba
uh it seems to have a will of its own it
seems to have um
coordination it's as though there's a
master bird which is giving orders but
it's not like that
it's what it is each individual bird is
following a set of rules
um and the emergent property of all
those rules is the
murmuration of the entire the
flocking of the entire flock
this has been shown beautifully in
computer simulations where
uh what the what the programmer does is
to program
a single bird
not a flock just one bird
with rules just half a dozen simple
little rules about keeping neighbors at
certain angles whatever it might be
having programmed one bird
the programmer then as it were clones up
that one bird
and and releases thousands of birds in
the computer
and see and then what you see what
emerges is the behavior of
of the whole flock
so the way genes program
what we see as the phenotype
is actually
done in that kind of recipe-like way
right
programming in simple rules which then
in now we're not talking about
individual starlings
behaving in relation to each other or
individual termites behaving in relation
to each other we're talking about cells
in the in the developing embryo
so the cells in the embryo are obeying
simple little rules local rules
in in one sense there is no there is no
blueprint
in a way the
what molecular biology textbooks say
when they say that dna is a blueprint
for a body that's not true it's actually
quite a bad fallacy it's not a blueprint
it's a program or a recipe it's a set of
rules
which are obeyed at the cellular level
and the subcellular level
and the consequence of all these little
rules being obeyed in all these little
cells
is that a body emerges
um i don't know whether that helps to
clarify the question you were asking
about the sort of the number of genes
you need in order to make i mean if you
think think think think recipe rather
than blueprint and i think that's that's
the key no yeah so i'm not sure if it
does answer the question i asked but it
answers an even better question that i
didn't think to ask because
i mean it's saying that in the space of
all
complex behaviors we can imagine complex
behaviors that are just the result of
some super genius intelligence doing
complex things we can also imagine these
emergent complex behaviors that result
from the concatenation of simple rules
and the kinds of behaviors that biology
is going to eventually find due to the
constraints of genes doing their thing
are these emerging things it's a lot
easier to find these simple rules that
can build up to something complex than
just be complex
yes and now and natural selection only
sees the
final phenotype right so that natural
selection sees the behavior that emerges
or the morphology that that emerges
natural selection doesn't see the genes
right but it's the genes that gets that
get favored in
in terms of the numbers of them that get
through to the next generation so
um
the
phenotype is the emergent property by
which the genes are selected there's
this kind of proxy
for the genes
i know there's the there's a lot going
on when we
mix up our our uh
genome or when we when our genome gets
altered through the generations part of
it is just sexual um
uh reproduction and sharing uh there's
very tiny details about horizontal gene
transfer at some level and of course
that there are mutations is there some
feeling for like in a modern relatively
mature species like birds or human
beings the relative importance of these
different factors uh in in changing our
genome through the generations is is it
is it sexual reproduction doing most of
the work in finding good combinations or
that's a good question
again i hadn't thought of it that way um
i don't think so i i could be wrong
about that um
because not all animals have sexual
reproduction
um so and and bacteria have something
much more
rudimentary than that bacteria
do a kind of
cut and paste
bits of genome in sort of rather
haphazard way
whereas in eukaryotes it's become
ritualized into the into the form of
meiosis and sexual recombination
um but once you've got proper sex once
you've got meiosis and proper sex
property recombination i'm not sure
it's possible to
easily answer that question i mean
mutation is the ultimate source of
variation but sexual recombination is
the more proximal way in which it it
it appears right i guess what i have in
mind is this very vague feeling that i
would like to make more quantitative
that the space of all possible genomes
is way bigger than we'll ever reach in
the history of evolution right so yeah
somehow there's
there's
places that we can easily get to in the
space of genomes and some and other
places are just you know terra incognita
will will never get there and i'm
wondering to what extent
we understand the difference between
where we might get to and where we'll
never will yeah that that that's
that is fascinating and and i i've tried
to
explore this a little bit uh in with
computer with very simple computer
simulations
um
you could say this something like this
i love the concept of the space of all
possible genomes
and um
the vast majority of
the that
multi-dimensional space is terra
incognita as you say
um
so
this is fundamentally why
major mutational steps major major leaps
in the
hyperspace of all possible genomes is
almost bound to be to lead to death yeah
it's got to be a it's got to be a a walk
through proximal regions of the
of the um
[Music]
cypress space
um
and um
this is why f fisher made a nice ra
fisher made a nice um analogy with with
the focusing of a microscope
he said
um
adaptive
an adapted animal a well-adapted animal
is like a microscope which is um in
focus now
um if the microscope is not quite in
focus
then it requires only a very small
tap to them to the microscope to make it
either
to get better or slightly worse
so
this is fisher's argument for why only
very small mutations are evolutionarily
important
a large mutation is equivalent to
bashing the microscope so so it either
goes
way way out of focus one way or where we
are to fix the other other way
assuming it's already nearly in focus
which it must be
in order for the the parent generation
to have survived
if the mutation is changing something in
the child generation
then it's got to be a small change
otherwise it's equivalent to moving the
tube of the microscope in a
by a whole inch
which is which is bound to make it to
make it worse so um
the space of all possible
uh
phenotypes
has been
most
vividly because simply explored in
snail shells
uh
because
the way a
not just snail shells actually but um
shells of other um creatures that
which
are not mollusks it's a it's a tube
that that un that unrolled the the the
snail shell grows the young snail grows
at the margin and it's it's a tube that
coils as it as it grows
and
uh a paleontologist called ralph
um
quantify this by saying there are only
three
three basic
variables that determine
how this
tube
unravels itself there's the rate at
which it expands there's the um
rate at which it moves out of the plane
so if you think about something like a
turret shell which which goes
um
which which which goes out of the plane
um
and an ammonite doesn't go out of the
plane and ammonite stays with within the
plane so that that
variable
is
zero
whereas a
taritella one of those things that looks
like a top oh yeah okay
has a high one so that that's that one
there's the the rate at which the the
rate at which the diameter expands as
the as the cube
grows and then there's the third
variable
so you just just these three variables
what that means is that all possible
snail shells will fit in a cube
just a straight dimensional space right
um which is beautiful yeah and so ralph
actually plotted this and i i did a
computer version of it as well
um
and there are great areas of this cube
which are
never visited by by nature they're
they're they're
terra igna incognito as you say
um and there are
corners of the cube which which are
actually populated by real
by real shells
so something like a an oyster or a
mussel
has a huge expansion rate
something like a taratella has a very s
slow expansion rate
um
well
that
model the raup
cube model is something you can
generalize conceptually into a hypercube
where it's not just three variables but
um but
dozens of them yeah but it's still the
same principle you can imagine the same
principle working if you could do the
you can't visualize it in three
dimensions but you have to think of it
in multi-dimensional space
uh and um
evolution however many dimensions you've
got evolution must be
a walk
through neighboring areas you cannot
suddenly jump from one part of the
of the hyperspace to the other because
that that's almost bound to be
uh
totally non-viable
and maybe this is a good way of thinking
about convergent evolution in some sense
i mean there are
very different genomes that can give
effectively similar phenotypes and and
we see that in the case of flying right
lots of different species have developed
wings in very different ways
that's right uh um well
four different
flights evolved fought four times in
insects pterodactyls birds and bats and
in different ways
in all cases there are four completely
different principles but the but the the
physics is the same
so the physics of flying is the same
whether you're a pterosaur or a bird or
a bat but that's do it by having
greatly elongated fingers
with uh membranes stretched between the
fingers pterosaurs do it by having one
elongated finger
just the fourth finger the the ring
finger
birds do it by having the whole arm
with with feathers
um hanging from it
um but once you've
dealt with that fundamental difference
the physics is the same and so you could
say it's convergent
um
there are much more striking examples of
convergence i mean the whole australian
mammal fauna
shows beautiful convergences to
the mammal foreigners in the rest of the
world uh um as you know
um
yes so convergence is a wonderful thing
and and it's it's great um
uh testimony to the power of natural
selection starting from different
starting points you end up with the same
thing because the
functional needs of the statement
because the physics is the same the eyes
have evolved many many times for the
same reason the physics of
of of forming
a usable image
uh using straight light rays
um
is the same whether you're an insect or
a prawn or or a bird or or
an octopus
um and
there are i mean compound eyes use
totally different kind of physics but
octopus eyes and
vertebrate eyes use the same physics
uh which it's a it's the same physics as
a camera yeah which produces an inverted
image whereas
the insect compound eye just a whole lot
of tubes sticking out in
different directions it's it's a sphere
a hemisphere
with lots and lots of tubes and so
depending on which tube of the light's
coming from you can tell
what's going on so in that case insofar
as there is an image it's not inverted
it's the right way up um
but anyway um eyes have evolved
dozens of times independently
convergently in many cases in the animal
kingdom isn't there i forget the name of
the species in australia but there's
something that looks quite like a dog
and acts like a dog and plays the role
of a dog but it's closely related to
kangaroos alas it's extinct uh you're
thinking of thylacinus
with the the tasmanian wolf
it it hung on in tasmania went extinct
in australia long ago the tasmanian wolf
survived in tasmania up until
the last century and the last one went
extinct that died in 1936
in hobart zoo
it's tr it's a great tragedy it was
it was thought to be
a menace to farmers it was thought to
worry sheep
and so they put a bounty on it
and it was it was hunted to death
uh and uh oh if only i would love to see
there's a there's a film
uh a movie an old black and white movie
of the last the last surviving thyla
sign and it looks just like a dog um
behaves just like a dog it's got a tail
stick straight out the back unlike a
dog's tail it's got stripes unlike a dog
um and it's got a pouch like a kangaroo
but um the behavior is just like a dog
you could imagine patting it and saying
sit up and beg and and it looks just
just like a dog because it does the same
job as a dog it it it
um it was a hunting animal like a dog
um and the skull is almost identical to
a dog there are one or two telltale
signs it's a favorite trick in zoology
exams to to give a
thylacine a skull
and they i think i think it's adorable i
think it's a dog's skull i mean i guess
there's different angles you can take on
this we i recently talked to eric
kirschenbaum i don't know if you know
him but uh he uh a zoologist who's
thinking about uh
what aliens will be like and he tries to
make oh yeah the case where they won't
be that different maybe because of these
forces of convergence that we see here
on earth
in contrast i had my evil twin the
biologist sean carroll uh on the show
and he's emphasizing the role of
contingency and chance and randomness
and unpredictability i mean where do you
come down on the question of if we ran
the tape backward if we evolved again uh
how would our ecosystem look like uh or
well i
yeah i'm i'm i'm on on the side of
convergence okay i think that natural
selection is so so powerful um on the
other hand of course the um
the physics is not necessarily going to
be the same if if if gravity is
stronger
uh
or weaker
then that will have entirely predictable
effects
uh if if gravity is stronger then you
will expect that
um
a spider would be built like a
rhinoceros with great death
and and conversely
if gravity is weaker then the rhinoceros
would be built like a spider
because the
um
of some simple physics you can you can
work out what why that would be
um
but if the physics was the same if the
gravity was the same
and if there is light
well there's got to be light because
it's got to have a source of energy but
if it's not shrouded in perpetual fog
say so that
light rays can be used to
uh form images then
i would
bet my shirt that you will get eyes
like uh
and probably
compound eyes and camera eyes i mean
that because these are just
to os the parabolic reflector is another
one another way of doing it of course
and there is one animal at least that
that uses that principle really what is
that um
uh yes scallops um scallops um i think
limpets too i'm not sure about about
limpets
um
have you you use the reflector principle
but but there are there are not that
many ways to form an image
and so um
assuming that that there is light and
that and there's no fog
and if they're not living in perpetual
mud or something like that
so that you can actually uh
light rays are available straight
straight light rays are available then
you will get eyes
um assuming that that there's an
atmosphere there must it may be
well yeah okay assuming there's an
atmosphere then you'll you'll have ears
um
sound waves
um
will you get wheels well um
the wheel perhaps depends upon the
prior invention of the road or
before
yeah is the absence of wheels an example
of the fact that uh even though it's
pretty straightforward to imagine the
usefulness of half a wing it is not
straightforward to imagine the
usefulness of half a wheel it's quite
difficult to imagine getting a blood
supply and and nerves
getting past the axle well it could be
bone i don't know
yes it it it's not inconceivable
um
i think that major difficulties part of
it i think also it as i said before we
don't work on on rough rough terrain um
so
uh if if the planet is
hard solid
flat rock then i think there's a better
chance of something like wheels evolving
well it's interesting that you mentioned
i mean eyes uh evolved many times
wings did not evolve that many times you
said four different types
for yes
proper
powered flight which goes on
indefinitely as opposed to just gliding
downhill
um that's only if evolved four times and
are the is the insect way of flying even
though they use wings is it very
different i mean i can see the
relationship in the other ones well the
yes it
the insect wing is not a part of is not
an a modified limb unlike all vertebrate
wings which are modified from the from a
limb from the arms
one dinosaur
with legs too um but with insects it's
an extension of the thorax it's an
outgrowth of the thorax
so it it doesn't use up
the limb
the limbs and that makes that's a good
idea because it means that all the legs
are available for
for running
um
insect uh flight muscle is interesting
most insects
have a flight muscle which is an
oscillator
instead of be having a downstroke and an
upstroke that's separate like
vertebrates do and like some insects
like dragonflies do
insects like bees and flies
have a flight motor which is which is a
it's a kind of
high speed shiver yeah and so it's
either on or off the the the all the
nervous system
says is switch switch machine on ah okay
or switch it off
and and the actual frequency with which
the wings beat
is mostly determined at the resonant
frequency of the
wing
rather than being under the control of
the nervous system
so that's a major difference but the
aerodynamics is probably similar
um
some insects are very good at hovering
uh and not very many birds are
hummingbirds are and
um
there's there's one kingfisher which is
which can hover properly
um
and they do it by a kind of figure of
eight sculling
motion
um so hover flies are brilliant at that
and hummingbirds are too they they too
use a kind of figure of a sculling is it
am i gathering from what you're saying
that
flight only evolved once in the instax
kingdom
i can't be sure of that
uh but as far as we know i can't be sure
of that yeah no it may be maybe more
than once and and i i i don't think we
know
uh
possibly the fact that
some insects have this oscillator
muscle oscillating muscle and other
insects have an up down up down up down
flight mechanism that might suggest two
different
independent evolutions of flight
okay interesting yeah i guess once you
have a thorax it's weird that the thorax
is where it came from but you know once
there is that capability yes
they kind of do it by um in in some
cases that muscles actually attach in
such a way there's a hinge and it pulls
up and down but in many insects
it's just a deformation of the thorax
which which does it it the the muscles
kind of pull on the thorax and the
changing shape of the thorax causes the
wings to move
and i i suppose i should give you an uh
an opportunity to talk about some of the
quirkier ways that animals have
developed flight uh i mean there are
things that just float right and
certainly there are things that glide
that you already mentioned
yes um
the book of course is also about uh
human flight
and uh humans also use
balloons and we use the lighter than
their principle balloons and airships
derivables
and i don't think i speculate in the
book about whether any animal does that
i don't think they do
um
it's commonplace to use it in water
right
where the and
helios fish have this beautiful thing
called the swim blaster which enables
them to
uh change their position of hydrostatic
equilibrium they have a bladder inside
and by altering the amount of gas in the
bladder
they can rise or of or fall in the in
the water
the same way a balloonist does by
changing the
aerostatic point of equilibrium
but i don't think any animal uses
hydrogen for example
um to fly with
to uh and they could but but it doesn't
seem to have evolved i i presume this is
just a resource constraint right there's
not that much access to lighter than air
gases
whereas there's plenty of access to
lighter than water
but
nature can be very ingenious uh in i
mean that
that there is hydrogen in
um
in um
well there's there's methane which is
which is lighter than okay lighter than
air
and one of the one of the things we have
to worry about with global warming is is
methane produced by by cars too much
yeah um so
animals can make methane and do
as a byproduct and so
could they make a
bladder of some sort to to hold it well
um insects and spiders have silk and
silk is very good stuff for making
balloons with them in um
he man-made balloons are sometimes made
of silk
so
you start to feel the ingredients are
not totally
absent but they don't seem to have been
put together you probably know that carl
sagan speculated about floating gas bags
or jupiter yes right yes because there's
no solid ground to land on so there it
might have might have been easier
yes um
yes the atmosphere of jupiter would be
very dense and therefore
um it would be rather like swimming in
water it would be more like uh fish um
having a swim bladder
in water on this planet that's a purpose
i think maybe the answer to this
question is no but are there examples of
animals that fly
in some sense by making artificial
enhancements to their physiology by like
picking up a leaf and using it as a
glider
oh yes i think so i think so um let me
think about that now i can't pick i
can't put my finger on it but it
wouldn't surprise me if spiders do that
um
spiders uh
when a spider is is about to start
building a web
it needs to have one line one one string
to start it off with
so what it does is to um
see in some spiders at least it
it it releases a thread of silk with a
little kite on the end and that little
kite
floats and when it happens to hit some
some say bit of a tree or something
it sticks there and that gives the
spider
something it can run along
and then
then it's a way that then it can start
building its web using that main guy
rope to start with so that's kind of
flying a kite
um
plenty of animals float
well plenty of spiders for example do
things called kiting
where they float into the
aerial plankton up in the high
atmosphere
um using their own using little using
their own silk
as a as a kite
am i good so that's
that's that that would be a good example
is would be would be kiting in in in
spiders am i making too much of a leap
to connect this to the whole idea of the
extended phenotype
the idea that you know our genes affect
not only our bodies but parts of our
environments and that's good i think
that would be rather good i i would i
would i wouldn't mind doing that okay
good that would be fine i mean why don't
you explain to the audience what the
idea uh your idea of the extended
phenotype is i mean it's a it's an
enrichment i think how we think about
how evolution acts on us
yes well we normally think of genes as
acting on phenotypes which are part of
the body in which the gene sits and so
this is commonplace the
wing is
wing of a bird is part of the phenotype
and so
um
natural selection works on
genes in the bird
which improve the aerodynamic efficiency
of the wing that's commonplace phenotype
something like a bird nest on the other
hand is not part of the bird's own body
and yet if you look at the shape of a
nest it's clearly a darwinian adaptation
the shape of it has been shaped by
natural selection
which must mean that there are genes for
nest shape in the case of some weaver
bird nests that the
the nests are very elaborate
oven bird nests the deaths are very
elaborate
and so these must have evolved in slow
gradual stages just like the body of the
bird if it evolves and yet this is not
part of the bird's body
so we have genes that are that i have an
extended phenotype
the the nest
is influenced by genes must be
it's an extended phenotype because it's
outside the body of the bird
um
artifacts like that are the most obvious
example of an extended phenotype
but i then carry the argument further
once you as it were bought into that
then
um
parasites
which in influence the
behavior of the host in which they sit
in order to make that host more likely
to be eaten by the next host in the
parasites life cycle something like a
fluke
which
is a
little flat worm
which
so to speak wants to get into a sheep
and it's in an intermediate host which
is a snail
so it needs the snail to be eaten by a
sheep
and it
um
makes the
uh or there is another one which sits in
an ant
and it needs the ant to be eaten by a
sheep
so what it does there is called a brain
worm
it arrows into the brain of the ant
and makes a lesion in the brain of the
ant exactly as a physiologist a
neurophysiologist might make a lesion in
the brain which causes the ant to change
its behavior
to make it more vulnerable to being
eaten by a sheep it makes it climb to
the top of grass stems instead of being
good at going underground which is where
that
would normally want to be
in the heat of the day at least
and so
um the brain worm this fluke this worm
inside the ant
is changing the behavior of the ant in
order to get itself into the next host
of the of the life cycle which is the
sheep well
the the change of the ants behavior
is extended phenotype of the
flux genes it must have evolved by
natural selection which means there must
be genes in the fluke for
changing the behavior of the ant it's
extended phenotype not direct phenotype
and then the next step in the argument
would just to take a parasite which
doesn't live inside its host like a
cuckoo
where the cuckoo
nestling sits in the nest
and
manipulates a foster parent of another
species
into feeding it and again
the the change in the behavior of the
foster parent
since it's obviously
favored by natural selection
is extended phenotype of the
cuckoo genes i mean it makes it almost
mind-boggling in the complexity of
trying to analyze this right because we
can we can easily see how
genes code for proteins and then you
might want to say well okay these
proteins
help or hurt in some way they have some
functions but in fact they there's this
very complex interplay of the
environment it's in and different levels
at which we can talk about things
exactly this is why it's way easier to
be a physician it's just another step
it's just just one more step i mean
already we start with protein the gene
influence protein which changes the
behavior of cells in the developing
embryo like we were talking about
earlier which changes the formation of
tissues which changes the
behavior
in the case of the nervous system and
then one more step
changes the nest building behavior which
changes the shape of the nest
uh
it's just one more step at the end of
this long long chain of causation which
starts with protein and goes on through
all the different steps in embryology
well and then all the way to societies
or you know our the way that we
technologically alter our environment
right i mean these then
uh are features that come into how our
own genomes evolve
i hesitate to go that far
when the reason is this
although it's true to say that
you could do a genetics of bird nests
i'm not it hasn't been done but not the
slightest doubt you could do it because
as i said these things have evolved by
natural selection that means there must
be genes affecting
the shape of
a
um
bird's nest um but in the case of a
human artifact like say
a building
um
it's not like that i mean there's
there's no gene for
romanesque architecture as opposed to
gothic architecture right um
that there might be a gene that makes an
architect a good architect or a bad
architect because he's a good draftsman
or something like that but
i i i'm almost confident in saying that
there'll never be a gene
that that
that affects the actual shape of a
building
okay there is a g that affects the shape
of a bird's nest yeah no i completely
get that 100 but then so let me let me
then push back on
the idea of
putting the gene at the center of
everything for exactly this reason you
know once we have
knowledge uh that that we can pass down
memes if you would like to call them
that but you know other whatever forms
of uh
information that persists over time and
affects our behavior
uh aren't we pushed to consider the
co-evolution of those things uh isn't
that isn't that almost an inescapable
way of thinking about it
i think so um
but by introducing memes you've as it
were made that work because they
actually
could be
replicators they could actually they
could be natural selection
not genetic selection but memetic
selection
of of
memes and that and there would then be
uh co-evolution as you say between genes
and memes and i
think that could happen i i wouldn't
rule that out in the way i would rule
out
extended phenotypic effects on
styles of architecture okay i think
i think i could imagine
um
mimetic selection of styles of
architecture and an architect sees a
particular way of of of
decorating
the tops of pillars or something oh that
looks neat i'll copy that right um
and so that could spread in a in a kind
of
quasi-genetic way
and that i get that that that would be
nice i mean
and and i bet that happens
with all sorts of things like the um
well desmond morris looked at the style
of painting boats in
in malta but
fishing boats have designs written
painted on them um or
the um
um
figureheads on on the front of sailing
ships
probably
might have been imitated sure that that
would be mimetic selection and i i could
buy into that
but i think uh again correct me if i'm
wrong but you are skeptical of attempts
to analyze selection of the level of of
groups or something like that right i
mean i'm not at all familiar with all
the details but i know there's a long
running debate about gene selection kin
selection group selection explanations
of altruism etc i mean do you think that
there's actually do you think that
debate is you know healthy and ongoing
or we basically know the right answer
well
you're talking to me about this and i'm
i'm a partisan i am um
i think i think i think we do know the
right answer but but if you talk to
somebody else they would disagree
sure so what is the right answer
fundamentally it's all gene selection
yeah okay um and um
uh i make a distinction between
replicators and vehicles
um an organism is a vehicle
um and um there is a sense in which use
because the vehicle because the organism
the animal
is the thing that actually does things
it's the thing that actually hunts or
escapes or rip or or mates or or
it's a thing that has sensor organs a
thing that has limbs at hands feet so
the the vehicle is an important
unit
of evolutionary agency
but it's not what's naturally selected
because because it dies
um the only thing that
goes on to the next generation and the
next and the next and the next is the
genes and so
the unit of selection in that sense is
the gene
the use of selection in the vehicle
sense is the individual
it's arguable and some would argue that
the group can be a vehicle in that sense
that would have to mean
that
a group
evolves adaptations for the propagation
of the genes that make that
that adaptation
um individuals clearly do i mean the the
shape of a nose the shape of a wing the
shape of a tail
these all affect the
individual's
ability to pass on genes
somebody might argue it i wouldn't
somebody might argue that groups also
are vehicles in that sense that there
might be
a property of of a group
which affects that group's ability
to pass on genes i can't see how that
would work i mean
it doesn't seem to me to be plausible
and so i i don't
buy into
group selection
yeah i think i think again i have no dog
in the fight as it were but it makes
sense to me that the information that is
being passed down is contained in the
genes in some sense so there is
something
special about them i mean in that sense
if we
aspire to a general theory of
replicators
is there something new that comes along
when you have memes or when you have
knowledge i mean that's the other thing
yeah
i mean i i think the value of the of the
meme idea is not so much as a
contribution to the study of human
culture although it may be
but rather
it's it's a way of saying
it doesn't have to be genes any any
replicator would do
and if you cast around and try to think
of an alternative replicator
a computer virus would be another
example um because it's self-replicating
uh and a meme is another example it's
self-replicating whether there really is
a natural selection of memes is an open
and interesting question
and and i suspect there probably is but
it may not be
very evolutionarily significant
whereas you can look at an animal and
say
everything about that animal
is all about increasing survival of the
genes that made that made it
could you ever
do that for memes maybe you could it's
not out of the question at least they
are bona fide in replicators so here's
the final uh
topic i want to get on the table here um
this has changed gears a little bit but
not not actually too much uh you were
very kind recently to say nice things
about my book the big picture on twitter
thank you for that um
but you couldn't resist the temptation
to take a jab at philosophers along the
way while while you did it saying that
you know you did i i forgot that
something about you know how i was
discussing philosophical things but in a
much more clear way than actual
philosophers would would do but i think
you know the discussion we've just been
having for last 10 minutes or so on
levels of selection and things like that
this is the kind of
arena in which it seems to me that
philosophy has a role to play that you
know there are scientific questions and
also general structural questions about
uh emergence and levels and
logic and reasoning and so forth so i
would like to see uh you know friendly
cooperation between the scientists and
the philosophers uh whereas you seem to
be a little bit more skeptical that
they're gonna be of any help
i like to talk about this because you're
one of the few people i know who who
can do could do both
and and um
in my naive way i feel that what
philosophers if their good ones do
is well is think clearly
and um help other people to think
clearly
but
thinking clearly is what i hope we all
do anyway
and so
what i don't
quite get is why
you need to
get a degree in philosophy where you
study aristotle and
lock
and and [ __ ]
and um
before you can think clearly and and um
clearly many people
do think clearly
um
on the other hand
when i attended that um
seminar in
um
wherever it was it's somewhere in new
york state was it that you organized
massachusetts in stockbridge yeah
yes that's right um
i was totally out of my depth um because
i i couldn't follow the jargon
um and i
am familiar with interacting
with
many of the scientists there like dan
well i think i've done dentists as a
scientist
or or jerry coyne
or
um
and
when i talk to dan bennett um
he he's such a clear thinker and i like
to think i am we can talk
together
without
having to
have recourse to
quoting the philosophers of
history
um and without the use of
philosophical jargon
so i i'm fully ready to be convinced
that
there is more to philosophy than just
thinking clearly
and it is actually necessary
to
deploy
the jargon philosophy in order to
do the job of thinking clearly and you
can convince me of that and i i just um
i feel completely naive about about that
that that matter well let me just say
something very briefly and hear your
response to it i think yeah uh you know
look there's plenty of scientists who
can't seem to say a sentence without
devolving into jargon very quickly also
i wouldn't i wouldn't necessarily uh
blame just philosophers for that but
what i think is in the modern academy in
universities
it's more a stylistic question of what
questions we consider important i had
dave reich on the podcast uh talking
about the genetics of ancient humans and
i said you know what is a species or
something like that and he says oh no i
can't talk about that that's philosophy
and you know uh and i get it i get
exactly
in that context no that's terrible well
yeah well yeah so i i think that uh it's
less about the substance what that means
that they're doing philosophy is they're
rather than making up a model that makes
some prediction for some experiment that
we can do in the next five years they're
thinking about foundational questions
about what these terms mean which are
unnecessary what we can get rid of and i
think that style of thinking can the
right parts it's not necessary for most
of science but for some kinds of science
that's kind of really really useful
i think it's totally important and and i
think that's what we all ought to be
doing anyway um so so we can't talk
sensibly unless we do
define our terms and find and decide
what it is we are talking about
um you're of course right that
scientists do use jargon all the time
but in a way that's kind of inevitable
if you um
if you're a physicist then if you're a
quantum physicist then you're using
the jargon of quantum physics which is
incomprehensible to
people outside and that's necessary you
can't you can't help that
um
similarly if you're an
immunologist uh you use jargon if you're
a
molecular biologist you use job and
you're talking about real things which
which actually are there in the real
world and
um and and you they got names
like sistron and operon and
that kind of thing you actually do need
those
um
the jargon of philosophy
also seems to have
a whole dictionary of
names
and i don't know what that what they're
for
there's one thing i think that's that's
like that's a good place i don't it
probably isn't fair enough i mean i i
would genuinely like to be convinced
actually good this is a longer
conversation we should have it sometime
over over in the pub sometimes yeah
yeah but so let me then uh just finish
up final question give us your your
feeling about the state of evolutionary
theory the modern synthesis and so forth
i know there's some people who would
argue that with improved understanding
of epigenetics and other factors that we
have replaced the modern synthesis with
something better uh do you think that
we the picture of modern natural
selection neo-darwinism the modern
synthesis is more or less correct and
it's a matter of firming up the details
or are there revolutions to come in that
basic understanding okay
um
i think
firming up the details is
uh
doesn't really do justice to what's
necessary because the um
the molecular biology revolution
is so
profound and what what it means is that
the coding of biology is digital
profoundly digital
um
i mean we already knew from mendel
that it was kind of digital i mean
mendelian genes are digital they don't
they don't blend
um
but the
dna of watson and crick
is digital
to the umpteenth degree it's exactly
like computer i mean
a chromosome is just a radical computer
tape
it it's quaternary rather than binary
and that
does have profound implications so
although it is in a sense firming up the
details
um
that covers a multitude
of in
important interesting
things
um so i think the modern synthesis is
correct
um but
um
i think that people who try to say the
modern synthesis is dead
they're overreaching themselves
but
um
the modern synthesis
what that
had over darwin was was the idea that
evolution is changes in gene frequencies
in populations those those were
mendelian genes
but we now know
what they are
in and express them in digital form
and uh we can
for example do taxonomy
working out the
family tree the relationships between
all living creatures animals plants
fungi bacteria
using
quantitatively precise counts
of the numbers of dna code letters which
which they have in common
it's just like
could it be the same kind of precision
as if you have
alternative
versions of the book of isaiah or
something um
that then you can compare them letter by
letter
um so this is a huge
advance
uh and um
understanding evolution at the level of
dna
uh it's
nothing nothing in the modern synthesis
is contradicted sure but the detail is
is the detail is huge and fascinating
and
darwin would be thrilled
i think it would be i think a future
generations are gonna have a lot of fun
things uh to add to the whole story so
richard dawkins thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast thank you very
much indeed
[Music]
you